مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في مجوز اعلن وزير
العدل الامريكي جارلاند انه اجاز اول
عمليه نقل لاصول مصادره من احد رجال
النخبه الروسيه الى وزاره الخارجيه
لاستخدامها في دعم اوكرانيا جاءت تصريحات
توغارلاند خلال استقباله المدعي العام
الاوكراني في واشنطن
من جهه قال المدعي العام الاوكراني ان
الاصول الروسيه التي سيتم نقلها ستستخدم
لصالح جهود اعاده الاعمار
تعادى الاتحاد الاوروبي في ختام قمه
الاتحاد واوكرانيا في كييف امس بدعم مساعي
اوكرانيا للانضمام اليه وقال الاتحاد
الاوروبي في بيان انه سيتخذ مزيدا من
الخطوات بمجرد تلبيه جميع الشروط المحدده
من قبله للانضمام للمفوض
من نجهته قال الرئيس الاوكرانيه هدف بلاده
واضح وهو بدء المفاوضات بشان عضيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي وشدد زينسكي على حاجه بلاده
للاسلحه بعيده المدى
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الوزير
ابلغ نظيره الصينيه تشينج بالغاء سفره الى
مجهين على دخول منطاد تجسس صيني الاجواء
الامريكيه وقال انه اوضح لنظيره للصينيه
ان دخول المنطاد الى الاراضي الامريكيه هو
انتهاك للسياده
البيت الابيض في احاطه ان وجود المنطاد
الصينيه في الاجواء الامريكيه هو انتهاك
واضح ومرفوض للقانون الدولي بنيه التجسس
واضاف ان البنت استعرض خيارات التعامل مع
المنطاد الصيني وان وزير الدفاع اقترح عدم
اسقاطه خوفا من المخاطر
قد قالت الخارجيه الصينيه ان المنطاد
الصينيه الذي رسلته الولايات المتحده مدني
يستخدم لاغراض البحث وخاصه الرصد الجوي
اضافه لوزاره ان المنطاد انحرف بعيدا عن
مساره المخطط له والنبي جين تاسفوا لدخوله
المجال الجوي الامريكي عن غير قصد دوال
اسباب خارجه عن ايراداتها
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل الاجراءات
الرئيس قيس سعيد واعتبرها محاوله للتغطيه
على فشل الانتخابات وانتقد الاتحاد
موقعصفه خطاب التحريض والتخوين من الرئيس
ضد الاتحاد وضد مكونات المجتمع المدني
واعلنا الاتحاد وانه قرر عددا من التحركات
اعتبارا من الاسبوع المقبل وانه سيعلن
عنها لاحقا ودعا النقابيين لتوحيد الصف
من جهته شدد الرئيسيه قيس سعيد على تطبيق
القانون على الجميع وقال ان دوله ليست
اللقمه يعبث بها حسب تعبيره واضاف خلال
تدشين لاحد الطرق السريعه جروا البلاد ان
الطرقات ليست ملكا خاصا لتغلق في اشاره
لاضراب نقابه الطرقات السياره التابعه
للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
مشاهدينا انتهى هذا الموجز شكرا لكم
واينما كنتم
[موسيقى]